welcome to cloud security basics a new
series where we explain the ins and outs
of securing your application on Google
cloud sound fun then stick around
because in this episode you'll learn
about the third of three distinct areas
of cloud security risk the platform
[Music]
hello cloud detected you may have
understood securing access and data but
what about the platform what makes the
physical and virtual hardware Google
provides secure once your data is in the
cloud how do you know it's really safe
what if the m's aren't being properly
isolated from other workloads leading to
a tricky tennis isolation exploit are
the physical devices being properly
secured and checked for malware what
about people at Google looking at your
data what if one of my hunch people gets
into a Google Data Center for your sake
I hope you know the answer to my
questions okay here's what we know
platform represents the physical systems
that house and deliver information it's
important to understand the abstract
notion of a user accessing information
is realized in physical systems and the
sum total of those systems is the
platform we often think of the platform
as a server-side thing but really it's
everything from the users fingertips to
the bid on the disk network in between
the server which runs applications and
so on but since we have the shared
security model it's important to
remember that Google is responsible for
ensuring the physical and virtual
hardware Google provides as operating as
it should luckily Google cloud services
are designed to deliver better security
than many traditional on-premise
solutions because Google runs on the
same infrastructure they make available
to their customers your organization
directly benefits from these protections
Google uses a multi-layer defense and
effort pros to security each layer from
physical data center components to
Hardware provenance secure boot secure
inner service communication secure data
and protected access to services from
the internet each of these has strict
controls for access and privilege and is
continually evolving let's dive deeper
into this so how does Google cloud
really protect the physical and virtual
hardware it provides well check this out
it's part of their ongoing efforts to
secure the cloud Google Cloud has 850
plus security engineers 200 billion
annual security investment a 24/7
active watch a hundred and sixty plus
academic research papers on security a
bug bounty program a penetration testing
program this shows the level of
investment Google puts into security
Google security teams triage investigate
and respond to incidents 24 hours a day
365 days a year and conduct regular
exercises to measure and improve
security detection and response on the
application side Google cloud provides
libraries and frameworks that prevent
developers from introducing certain
classes of security bugs like cross-site
scripting vulnerabilities and web apps
on Google cloud automated tools like
fuzzers static analysis tools and web
security scanners are used to detect
security bugs on the access side Google
makes a heavy investment in protecting
Google's employees devices and
credentials from compromised using
technologies and strict policies for
physical computer data and network
security access management security
logging and so much more
ah that's it I know the answer to Brad's
question hello detective I see you've
been quite busy and solved my little
question what's really keeping your data
safe once it's in the cloud and you
found the key concept clients secure
their applications and Google secures
the infrastructure the platform is
secure because that's Google's
responsibility and security is
foundational to everything Google cloud
does from designing data centers to
software to processes but most
importantly because Google cloud runs on
the very same infrastructure provides to
customers all of those protections can
be used by people like you to protect
your business very good very good you've
answered today's question but be ready
because next time I'm going to make you
dig deeper into the platform to see
exactly how Google cloud protects the
users data so there you have it another
episode of cloud security basics next
episode will focus on how Google cloud
protects the data that lives on their
servers in the meantime if you want to
take a deeper dive in how Google secures
its platform then check out the article
linked in the description below and stay
tuned for the rest of the cloud security
basics series because when it comes
security you can't let bad actors win
[Music]